"This text is being provided in
a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings."
[applause]
>> Good morning
>>
Good morning
>> I'm Leanne Potter. I
direct educational outreach at
the Library of
Congress.  I'm so happy that
all of you are here for
this really terrific event.
How many of
you, and I'm going to ask you
guys to dim that light for
a second so I can see a raise
of hands.  How many
of you have ever tried
something new?
Yeah... I kind of thought so.
So... you know how when you try
something
new, you're really excited about
it and then sometimes you get
a little scared about it?  You
know how that
is?  Yeah... that happens to all
of us.
And here at, here, well... let
me put
it this way.  When you're
excited, and
even when you're scared, it
always helps to have somebody
who
is encouraging you and somebody
who is as
enthusiastic and as excited as
you are about whatever
that new thing is, you know?
And... here at the library,
we've been
trying a lot of new things
lately.  We want
to make sure that everybody
knows about
this amazing library and its
incredible
collections and how much we can
learn here
at the library.  And
we're trying a bunch of new
things, you know, like maybe
inviting a superstar wrestler
actor
to come and read a book and
fortunately for
us, we have a librarian
of Congress who shares our
excitement and encourages and
leads us with her energy and
her enthusiasm.  So... I'm
really honored this morning to
be the
one who gets to introduce
you to Dr. Karla Hayden.  The
14th librarian of Congress.
She earned
her Ph.D. at the University of
Chicago.  She began
her career as a children's
librarian.  She led
the Pratt Library in Baltimore.
She was the
president of the American
Library Association and
she's absolutely aware of the
power of reading and
the magic of a good
story.  Dr. Hayden?
[cheering and applause]
>> So...
what an exciting day.
You didn't know all that other
stuff she was
saying when I was here seeing
how you all
are.
I'm so excited because this is
such a special program.
So...
I'd like you and I got a chance
to meet a lot
of you, and I'm supposed
to say
here, it says please hold your
applause until I introduce
all the schools, but let's see
how that works.
I do have to ask you, we have
young people that
are not here with us in
Washington, D.C., so... when we
get to them, could you give
them a big
hand?  Because...
from Washington, D.C.,
right here, in the Coolidge
Auditorium, we have students
from
Capitol Hill Montessori
school.
[applause]
bishop
John T.
Walker school
for boys, Plumber
Elementary School,
Kimball Elementary
School,
Landon
Elementary School, right
here in D.C., we have to also
welcome and we have
students from the Langley
School in
McClain, yay!
And... we have students, like I
told you from across the
country who are watching us
live on
Facebook and YouTube.
[applause]
>> So...
let's give a big Washington,
D.C.,
McClain, Virginia welcome to
the
Calverton School in
Huntington, Maryland.
[cheering and applause]
>> We love
you.  The
Tinmouth Elementary School
in Tinmouth
Vermont and the John Diaw
school
in
Englishtown, New Jersey.
Welcome all of you.
As you can imagine, it's an
exciting day at the library of
Congress.
We have more events in the next
few days that you might
want to think about.
On
Friday, at 10:30, I'm doing a
special story time
with the one and only
Paddington Bear.
He'll
be here in person or in bear,
taking pictures with children
that will be there and on
Wednesday, next Wednesday, at
11:00 a.m., we're going to have
a holiday
story time in the Great Hall
and we'll have a menorah and
we'll
have a good time.  We hope
you'll join us.
Now... today, wow.
In September, 1936, the
Viking Press published the
story of
Ferdinand.  Written by Monroe
Lief and illustrated by
Robert Lawson.  This book
became so popular that
by 1938, it
was already in its eleventh
printing.  Today... as
I mentioned a little earlier,
we have the son of
Mr. Lief, Andy
Lief so let's give him a welcome
again.
[cheering and applause]
>> And, as I think you
know, later this month,
20th Century Fox will be
releasing a
feature-length animated film
based on the
book.  And... the person who is
joining us
today, actor and wrestling
superstar, Mr. John Cena
will be --
[cheering and
applause]
--
will be the voice of
Ferdinand and... today,
yes, today,
and as soon as I leave and I'm
sure you're ready,
he'll read the book and he's
going to talk to us a bit and
you'll
have a chance to ask him
questions.
So... as he reads, you'll see
the pages of the book, not just
the pages of any
copy of the book, but
the pages from the original
1936 edition, the actual one,
that
was submitted to the Library of
Congress
to have a copyright.  And
it's right here.  You probably
know the story of
Ferdinand has been translated
into
more than 16 languages and it's
included in Time Magazine's 100
best children's
books of all
time.
So... it reminds us that the
best version
of yourself means helping
others and that's something that
our special guest today, Mr.
John Cena,
does all the time.  He's
actually set the
record for Make a Wish
granting with over 500
wishes.  Please join me in
welcoming 16-time world
champion
wrestler, five-time U.S.
wrestler, record-setting
Make a Wish granter, star of
blockbuster
movies, the man you're here to
see, Mr.
John Cena.
[cheering and applause]
>> Thank you very much.
What a, what a special
day.  I'm going to put my 1938
edition
Ferdinand next to the first
print, 1936 edition.
We're going to look at the 1936
edition, but not touch
it.  It's very, very delicate
and very
important and the people from
the library of Congress were
very thorough in saying
like, hey... don't touch the
first book.
So... I'm going to oblige their
wishes and we're going to do
this
thing.  I'm very, very excited
to be here today.  I'd
like to first thank the
Lief family for allowing me to
do something like this.
Without the creation of this
story,
I wouldn't be here reading to
you today.  It's a great
honor, I'm grateful to be
chosen for the movie that's
coming out.
But it starts with a famous
story.
This story
has an important and powerful
message, the book has been in
publication over 80 years now,
that means
this book is twice as old
as I
am.
[laughter]
>> But I think the reason that
the
message continually gets
sent and absorbed year after
year is because it's easy
to digest.  Ferdinand is such a
large bull,
people think he's one thing,
but the advent
of him loving flowers humanizes
him.
You realize
that what you see isn't always
what you get.  It's an
important story and certainly a
story close to my heart
as the life that you see that I
live on
WWE television mirrors kind of
the story of
Ferdinand.  I go through a lot
of pressure every day to change
who I am and
there's a lot of folks using
some negative influence out
there to try to make me change
my
values.  But... it just makes me
stand up and be proud of who
I am and be proud of those
values and not change to try
to please someone else, just be
proud of who I am.  So...
with that said... we have an
excellent story today, I'm going
to
read and they said I was going
to talk after I
read, but I already switched it
up, I already talked,
because I want you to have as
much time as you can for
questions afterwards.  I look
forward to
hearing from you after we hear
from this.  Shall we?
The story of Ferdinand.
my loan agreement from the
Library of Congress.
Promise to return
this book, the penalty is quite
heavy.
Once upon a time in
Spain there was a little bull
and his name was
Ferdinand.  All the other
little bulls he lived with
run, jumped and
butt their heads together, but
not
Ferdinand.  He liked to sit
quietly and smell the flowers.
Hada favorite spot out in the
past your
under a cork
tree.  It was his favorite
tree and he'd sit in the shade
all day
and...
smell the flowers.
Sometimes his
mother, who was a cow, would
worry about him.
She was afraid he'd be lone
some and
all by himself.  Why don't
you run and play with the other
little
bulls?  Skip and butt your head,
she would say?
Ferdinand
would shake his head.  I like
it better here where I can
sit quietly and smell the
flowers.
he wasn't
lonesome and though she was a
cow, she let him sit there and
be
happy.  As the years went
by, Ferdinand grew and
grew until he was very big and
very strong.
other bulls who had grown up
with him in the same pasture
would fight each other all
day.  They would butt each other
and stick each other with their
horns.  What
they wanted most of all was to
be picked
to fight in the bull fights in
Madrid.
But not
Ferdinand.  He still liked
to just sit quietly under the
cork tree and smell the
flowers.  One
day, five men came in very funny
hats, to pick
the biggest, fastest, roughest
bull, to fight in the bull
fights in Madrid.
All
the other bulls ran around
snorting and butting, leaping
and
jumping so the men would think
they were
very, very strong and fierce.
And pick them.
Ferdinand knew they wouldn't
pick him and he didn't care.
So, he went to his
favorite cork tree to sit down.
He didn't look where he was
sitting and instead of
sitting in a the nice cool
grass in
the shade, he sat on
a bumblebee.
and a bull sat
on you, what would you do?
You
would sting him and that's
exactly what this
bee did to Ferdinand.
Wow!  Did it hurt.
Ferdinand jumped up with a
snort, he ran
around puffing and snorting,
butting and pawing the ground
as if he was crazy.
The five men saw him and they
all
shouted with joy!
Here was the largest, and
fiercest bull of all!  Just the
one
bull for the fights in Madrid.
They took him away
for the bull fight day
in a car.
And what a day it was.  Flags
were flying, bands
were playing.
All the
ladies had flowers in their
hair.  They had
a parade into the bull ring.
First came the
banderilleros who had would
stick him and
make him mad.
Then came the
picadores with
long spears to stick the bull
to make him
madder.  Then came the
Matador, the
proudest of all.
He was very handsome
and bowed to the ladies.  He
had a red cape
and a sword and was supposed to
stick the
bull, last of
all.  Then came the bull, you
know who that
was, don't you?
Ferdinand the Fierce and all
the
banderilleros were scared of
him.  He ran into the
middle of the ring and everyone
shouted and clapped.  They
thought he
was going to fight fiercely and
buck and snort and stick his
horns around.
Not Ferdinand.
When he got to the middle
of the ring, he saw the flowers
and all the lovely
ladies hair.  He just sat down
and quietly smelled.
fierce, no matter what they did.
He
just sat and smelled.  The
banderilleros were made and the
picaderos were madder and
the Matador was fierce and
cried because he couldn't
show off his cape and sword.
So, they had to
take Ferdinand home.  And for
all I know, he's sitting there
still, under his favorite cork
tree,
smelling the flowers just
quietly.  And he is very happy.
The end.
>> What a cool story? And what
an important message?  Being
different's okay.  We're not
all alike and we should be
proud that even if you look
around in this audience,
we're all different.  We should
be okay being
different.  Because...
even if you're different like
Ferdinand and
you like to smell the
flowers, as long as you're
happy, that's cool.   Thank you,
guys
for listening to a wonderful
story and if you guys have any
questions for me, now's the
time.  So... fire away.
excellent.
going to do the questions, I
have four colleagues that are
stationed
right over here is Abby, over
here is Katherine, over
here is Sasha and I've guilt a
might.
-- got a mic.
make a big circle,
okay?  How about you?  I'm not
going to hand you the mic,
I'm going to hold it.  Speak
really clearly and the deal here
is, we're asking questions.
Okay...
so you can't just say "oh I
love you."
You can't do that, okay?
It's gotta
be questions, all right?
>> Here we
go
>> My name is Adrienne
and can you tell me how you
and Ferdinand connect?
>> Yeah... that's a good
question.  How do Ferdinand and
I
connect?  Ferdinand is
misunderstood.  People think
because he
looks some way that he should
be something.  And a lot of
times, in WWE, I'm very
misunderstood.  There's a lot of
people out there chanting at
the top of their
lungs for me to do something
that I really don't want to
do, but just like Ferdinand, I
make sure I stand proud of what
I believe in and I'm happy.
When you were a boy
, did you want to
be a wrestler
>> Say it again
you want to be a
wrestler or do what Ferdinand
did
>> When I was first born, I
opened my
eyes and I was like "what's
going on?  Wow!  This
place is weird, I
can't hold
my head up."  I'm
kidding.  As a young person, I
was very attracted and taken
aback by WWE.  I have an
imagination, like
all of you guys and these WWE
wrestlers really spoke
to my imagination.  They were
larger than life and doing
these amazing things and I said
to myself, as a
young person, one day, I'd
really like to be
a world champion and here I am,
a
16-time world
champion.  That doesn't mean
I've
lost it 16 times, but I've done
okay
>> What
inspired you to be in this
book?
>> Well...
the story is very special
and... it's been in publication
for over 80
years.
And I think when you read it,
just like we all listened, even
though sometimes the words
can get old, it never gets
misunderstood.  I think
the message is really cool.  I
was very happy to partner up
with
the folks making the movie.
The animators that made the
movie
are very gifted and once you
guys see the movie, I think
you'll all agree, it was a
great thing to be part
of.  I think you guys are all
going to enjoy it
>>
Before we go to my friend over
here, I have a question from one
of the kids in the school
watching over live stream
>> Thank you, guys, on the
internet, thanks.
[laughter]
>> The name of the student is
Trevor.  He's in fourth grade
at the
Calverton School in
Huntington, Maryland.  His
question
is, dear John Cena, do you love
what you do or do you ever wish
to do something else?
>> This
is an important message from
Ferdinand and if I could leave
you
with one bit of information.  I
know we'll talk a lot today
so sometimes your attention
span will go away, you may
want to look at your phone or
something, take this with you, I
promise
you, you have a long road
ahead.  Make sure
you do what you love.
Because...
you asked if I would want to do
anything else?  No, I want to
be right here, right now, with
all of you, reading a wonderful
story, preparing to release a
wonderful movie to the world and
then, hopefully, if I get what
I want for Christmas, go back
to my WWE family and do what
I love.  So... it's, it's
okay, through life you'll have
pressures around you of
people trying to make you do
certain things.  If you do what
you
love, you never call it work.
Because... right now,
we're having fun and it ain't
work.
I'm doing exactly what
I'd like to do.  It's a great
question
>>
My name is Michael and
I wonder, do you like being in
the ring?
>>
Do I like being in the
ring?
>> Yes
>> When I'm doing
well.
[laughter]
>> It's all so exciting that the
crowd noise is
fantastic and the lights are
amazing and the fans are great,
but
there are those times when you
let's say, finish second
place.  And those are, those
are tough times, but... it
keeps you wanting to get better
and come back for more.
Jay and one question,
actually two questions
>>
Excellent
>> What's your
favorite book as a kid?
>> My
favorite book was called Cars
and Trucks
and Things that Go.
I'll give you a spoiler alert
why,
because I love cars and trucks
and
things that go.
[laughter]
>>
Okay, second part?
>> What's your favorite thing
to do on Smackdown
Live?
>> Oh... I think the easiest way
to put that
is be a part of Smackdown
Live.  Because folks like you
are entertained by
it, thank you, two good
questions
>> Is it hard being a
wrestler and being an actor at
the same time?
No.  Because you just get to be
imaginative.  You get to create
and you get to have fun and
it's tough,
it's a lot of hard work, but
it's fun
to do both.  Good question.
>>
My name is Ima.  I
want to know, when
you
started your career?  When did
you start your
career?
>> When did I start? Well...
I'll answer that question,
with a question.  How old are
you?
>> Nine
>>
Nine.  It might have been
well before you were born,
so...
it's been
awhile.  Uh... I started my
career in 2002
on television,
so... it's been about 15 years.
I see a lot of
hands, this is great
>> We have a question, also,
from our friends who are
watching remotely and this one's
from a fourth
grader.  Did you listen
to the story as a child and did
you relate to it
then?
>> Well... as a child, I knew of
the story,
growing up, I knew of the
story, amazingly
enough, the first time I read
the book from cover to cover
was for this.  And it was
because I wanted to make sure
it was really important to send
the message of Ferdinand.
So...
like you guys, I'm being
introduced to
such a famous book and I can
see now why it's been
around for so long and touched
so many generations.
people like
Peyton Manning?
>> Well...
I was very thankful that I
didn't
have to play football against
Peyton Manning, but yes,
he was funny and goofy and I
thought he did an excellent
job in the movie.
name is Xavier, were you ever
scared when you first
got in the ring?
>> Ooh! Was I ever scared when
I first got in the ring?  I'm
scared all the time.  I was
scared
behind the door to come out and
talk to you guys, but it's your
ability
to understand that you're doing
something awesome and you're
going
to be nervous and you're going
to
doubt yourself at times, just
like when I'm in the ring, but
that's kind of what life is
about.  It's kind of
overcoming your fears and being
able to take
chances to do some cool stuff.
Yes... I was
nervous.
I'm always nervous.  But I
always do my best to
go out there anyway.
>> What
was your favorite sport before
WWE?
>>
What is my --
>> Favorite sport before
the WWE?
>> Say it again, I'm
sorry
>> What was your favorite sport
before
WWE?
>> I played football in high
school,
I played football in college.
I'll have to say football.
is Cassandra and
I'm in first
grade
>> Say that again.
is Cassandra and I'm in
first grade.  Ferdinand likes
to look at flowers, what do you
like to do?
>> Ferdinand likes flowers, what
do
I like to do?  I also
like flowers, my favorite flour
-- flower
is the rose, and little known
fact about me.
like to
sit, and relax and just like
Ferdinand, sit and smell the
flowers
>> We have another
question from somebody watching
live.
This time,
they're asking a question
via Twitter.
If you were to do another
animated movie, what character
would you
like to voice?
>> The
animated UN
-- universe is
great, you can start with
nothing and build a short story
about
it.  So I guess it depends on
the powerful subject
matter.
This was easy.  They asked me if
I wanted to be Ferdinand and I
was in.  The subject matter is
great, I knew the people making
the movie were great, I
knew they'd create a wonderful
universe.  I don't know,
hopefully I
get to do it again, we'll see
what happens.
Maximo.  Would you like to
continue your wrestling streak
or just smell the flowers?
>> Well...
one is a little less
physically-demanding, so there
are
times when I'd rather smell the
flowers, but I do like being
able to perform for audiences,
as you can tell.  I enjoy
being here with you guys and
there's nothing more exciting
than being
in a WWE ring, so I think I'll
go with that one.
by the way
>> My
name is Milo.
What is your favorite part in
the story of Ferdinand?
>>
Okay... that's a good
question.  I was peculiar why
the five men
had funny hats.
Because... if you look at the
picture,
they do have really, really
funny hats.  And... in the
story, I think that's a nice
little detail that the men had
funny hats.  But... my favorite
part is
when Ferdinand runs out into
the middle of the
arena and everybody thinks he's
going to fight really fierce
and it's
because he sees all the flowers
and it reminds him of
home, he sits down and is just
enjoyably happy smelling the
flowers.
about
you which is wrong?
>> Ooh! Okay. That's a great
question.  What do people often
think about
me which is wrong?
That, I always kind of like to
be
what you see on television.
I
truly enjoy my time in the WWE,
but... I also
enjoy a lot of other stuff.
And... even
if some people think it doesn't
make me
look cool or seem tough, it
doesn't mean that I don't enjoy
it.  So I guess people think I'm
a big tough guy
all the time and that's wrong.
to know how you think, how you
think you would be the best
part as Ferdinand when you two
or so
different?
>> Say it again
>>
How would you think you
were the best part as Ferdinand
in the
movie?
>> Okay... so, this is going to
sound weird.  I think
the best part in Ferdinand the
movie
is played by the calming goats.
Here
I am, I'm Ferdinand, this is
great, but my favorite
character in the movie is
a calming goat named Lupe.
When he shows up, you'll
understand why.  That's my
favorite
character
>> This is the question from
Cameron in the fifth grade in
Huntington.  How would you
explain why reading is so
important for
children?
>> Well... what a wonderful
building to be in to
answer that question.
There is a small
hallway with a tile fixture
that's extremely small above the
arches.  In brilliantly laid
tile
simply says knowledge is power
and that couldn't be more
correct.  And in a place with
almost
unlimited knowledge, as the
books keep pouring in and
materials
keep pouring in, it's certainly
important to be sharp
and be educated, because with
knowledge comes power.
So...
that's why reading is important.
>> My name
is Emily and how long
have you been
auditioning?
>> Man, it
was tough.  They had me talk a
lot.  No... I'm
just kidding. It was very fun
because... amazingly enough, the
people that
animate, the people that draw,
they're like big
kids.  They're so fun to be
around.  They want to make these
crazy
things and these wild and
imaginative things happen.
The audition was easy.  I'm
like a big kid
too.  They're like, let's make
this movie and we did it.
Ferdinand?
>> Well... I think Ferdinand's
really
cool.
Because, in the book, you can
see he doesn't want
to do what the other bulls do.
His mom worries about him
a lot.  Once she takes the time
to talk with Ferdinand,
she's like "he's going to be
okay."  So, I think it's
really important that it's,
even if you do
something different, that a ton
of people don't do,
even when they're pressuring
you to do it, it doesn't mean
you
can't be happy.
I thought that was a fun
and important message to send.
Alex.  Who is your enemy in
WWE?
>> Ooh! There's
an old saying that you are your
own worst
enemy, so it's probably me at
some times.  You
know, I don't really have any
archenemies, I'd say.  It's
really just a very competitive
environment
where we all want to be
champion,
so... I guess with me giving you
that answer, whoever is
champion.
my name is
Jayden, who is your favorite
wrestler in the
WWE?
>> Whoo! My favorite
wrestler of all time?  That's a
good question.  I know when I
was
your age, I really liked
Hulk Hogan.  I thought he was
larger
than life and a super hero,
nowadays, this is going to
sound weird.  I'd say my
favorite of all time is the tie
between two people.  One, Vince
McMahon, because I think he's
one of the greatest performers
ever in
WWE, two and I'd say a tie, I'd
say
a tie is The
Rock.
[cheering and applause]
He's just got an
electricity like no other.
And the eyebrow
thing
>> My name is
Naomi.  I wanted to ask, do you
do
your own stunts?
>> Actually, it's
a very elaborate process.  When
we film a
WWE event.  I do all the talkie
talkie and when we have
a chance to do action, we stop
and
a guy who looks like me comes
in and we
do all my own stunts.
It'd be easier if
-- yes, I do my own stunts.  I
knew that wasn't
going to hold up for more than
two seconds
Summer.  What
do you imagine yourself doing
in ten years?
>> I just
hope that I can continue to, to
tell
stories and actually call it
work.  This is
the greatest thing to be able
to do, to
be able to work hard, but at
the end of the day, do something
you love.  So... if ten years
from now I can continue to
keep doing this, it's
going to be
great
>> My name is
Charlotte, my brother loves
your story
Thank you.  It
was about time we had a
statement instead of a question.
That
was a very good one
>> My name is
Devon and why did you quit WWE?
Why did you quit
WWE?
>> That's a good question. I
don't know why anybody would
quit WWE.  I'm... I mean, I'm
going to give
you a spoiler alert.  I'm still
there.  So...
here's
the thing, here's the low down,
very interesting
question, because I'm not there
right now, so... what happens
is, I got this full-time job
with
WWE.
And then the phone rings and
somebody's like, hey
man, you want another job.  I
say "yeah, but
I can't let this one go" and
they're like "take
a break and come back."  I'm
like
"really?"
Yeah!  Cool!  I'm doing two jobs
at once.
is Shawn.  I was thinking, when
you were a kid --
did you ever think you were
going to make it into the
WWE?
>> Not for a second. I was
like,
man, there's no way I could ever
do that, but that was
when I was a little kid.  I
always kept
it in my mind, if I worked
hard, maybe I'd
have a chance.  When a got a
chance, I wasn't a
superstar overnight.
It was a lot of -- I swung and
missed a lot, but through hard
work and not giving
up, I eventually took a very
long time when I eventually
became a WWE superstar.  As a
young kid, I didn't think I'd
make it.
question.
How do you make a connection
with
Ferdinand?
>> How do I make a connection
with Ferdinand?
>>
Here's the cool thing
about Ferdinand.  I think
everybody in this room can make
a connection with Ferdinand.
We all interact with a bunch of
people every day if you look
around.  We
all look around in the room and
everybody's different.  At one
point or another, probably
everybody in this room
has been misunderstood and if
you've been
misunderstood for even one
second, whether
you know it or not, you have a
connection with Ferdinand.
Devon, a fifth grader.  What
children's book did you
enjoy as a child that touched
your heart like
Ferdinand?
>> Well... we've
talked about mechanical
obsession that
I had, I'll even say again that
I, aside
from cars and trucks and things
that go, I
gravitated towards a lot of the
works of Dr. Seuss.  I thought
Dr. Seuss was a
wonderful way of telling
stories and
his world were so bizarre and
imaginative, as
a kid, I gravitated towards Dr.
Seuss
as well
>> My name is Delaney, do you
know why
they decided to film Ferdinand
this year?
to make Ferdinand this year?
Well...
believe it or not, the guy who
directed Ferdinand, the studio
that made Ferdinand
started on this movie in 2010,
seven years ago, so...
it took seven years to make the
movie and
why they waited until
2010, I have no idea.  This is
also a fact about the movie. It
was an animated movie
way back in the day, it was
about six minutes long
and very well-received. It won
a
bunch of awards.  I think maybe
because it was a
shorter animated movie, is why
they
waited so long to make it an
animated movie
>> My name is Naomi,
I want to know, do you think
you'll
carry a legacy?
I think I'll carry a legacy?
That's for
you guys to decide.  Whether I
do or not, I'm having a fun time
and doing what I enjoy and
that's most important.
Komani.  What's the
hardest challenge or struggle
you face?
>> Not enough
hours in the day.
I want to do all this cool stuff
and then the
day just runs out.
So... maybe if there was a
little
more time in the day.  I could
be
able to do more fun stuff.
But... for the most
part, it's all pretty cool.
Just not enough time.
Hi... my name is
Tyrese.
Where do
you practice at for WWE?
>> I practice
at my trash talk.
[laughter]
>> Keep that real sharp in case
somebody
trash talks against you.
Practice on my
fitness.
Make sure I'm real
strong.
Sometimes you have to be strong
and one more thing.  This is
something
I practice on and you guys can
watch WWE
and know that I'm not kidding.
I practice
on my tolerance.
Because the audience is
everybody from around the world.
There are some
groups of the audience that
like me and there are some
groups
of the audience that don't like
me.  When those groups
that don't like me yell really
loud that I'm not any
good, I don't turn around and
say "you can't say
that" because they can say that.
So... it's actually, believe
it or not, my
time in the WWE has made
me have a greater appreciation
for all of you out there.
That's
the thing I practice the most
is tolerance.
fourth
grader.  How did you come up
with the phrase "you
can't see me?"
>> Ooh! How did
I come up with the phrase "you
can't see
me"?
I can't take credit for it.  My
youngest brother Shawn who
doesn't go by
the name Shawn.
He goes by Boog.  He dared
me to do it on television.  The
very first time I
played my theme song, he heard
it and was like
"that's awesome."  He started
dancing, doing something
like this.  I was like "you
look ridiculous" and he said
"ridiculous enough for you to do
it on
TV?"  I was
like... of course.  Back then, I
thought nobody was
paying attention.
I've got a
guy now saying you can't see
me.  I've been doing it
15 years and nobody can see me.
I'm actually invisible.
name is Lily and my question
is, how did you get into
starting --
how did you like... why did you
want to start wrestling?
because I've always been pretty
strong
and in good
shape.  I really enjoy it.
I like to watch the programs, I
like to keep up on the
superstars.  It's something that
I enjoy even though
I'm not involved.  So...
it's essentially like
a dream come
true
>> My name
is Jackson.  I wonder if you
ever got
bullied at school before?
>> Yes.
Yes I diet not only in
school and as a young man, I
was bullied a lot
because I didn't look like
everybody else, because I didn't
talk like everybody
else.  It was some very
difficult times.  Bullying is
very
difficult to deal with, but...
here's the thing, I
get bullied every day.  With
the advent of social
media and everyone that can
comment on your page, a
lot of people tell me that I'm
really not any
good, I've been called pretty
much everything, but... like I
said,
my experience with all of you
guys over the years is great
tolerance.  The
best advice I can give you for
all of that.
Don't pay
it any mind.
Certainly tell someone about it,
but
don't sweat it.  Those people
really are just
wasting their time anyway.
Chances are, more often than
not, they're going through some
issues that they can't really
deal with.
So...
yes, I was bullied then, I'm
bullied
now, but I don't pay it any mind
at all.
you like doing
animated movies?
>> I like doing
animated movies, because I'm
not very animated with
my own body.
Kidding.  I enjoy
both and everyone often asks
me, what
do you like
more?  Animated
movies or Ferdinand movies?
It's like one day paint inning
paint and
the next with pen, you get to
make
art or clay, but it's just
different forms.
that
you accomplished?
>> Have
I ever had a dream that...
>> You
accomplished?
>>
Oh!  I mean, every single day.
I'm able to live a
dream every single day.
Although... I had this
one weird dream.  I'll talk
about that later.  That's
okay.
[laughter]
>> This is a question from
Robert, fifth
grader.  As a kid,
did you ever get peer
pressured?
If so, what did
you do?  If you saw someone
else being teased,
what did you do?
>> I was peer pressured a lot
as a kid.  I'm peer
pressured a lot as an adult as
well.  We go to
school with a bunch of people
and there are groups of kids we
want to be with and groups of
kids we don't mesh so well with
and we always kind of try to
find out who we are and where
we're going to go in life.  And
sometimes, we let people make
those decisions for
us.
Every single time I've let
those folks make a decision for
me, it's really wound up
disastrous.  I guess my advice
when
it comes to peer pressure is
just listen to everything around
you and be
aware of everything around you
and make your own
choice.
Because... then at least you'll
be happy with it at the
end of the day.
you do 1,000 push-ups?
>> I can, I can
easily do 1,000 push-ups if I
start now and end in 2020.
But
I'm not going to start now.
We're just going to
speculate that I can do the
1,000 push-ups
>> All right...
we're going to take one last
round of questions.  So... this
is
my last question here and then
we'll head over there, there
and back, okay?
>> My name
is Leslie.  And...
what does it feel like to be
a role model out of the ring
and in the ring?
>>
That's, that's very kind
words.  That's a, I owe you a
thank you,
sir.  That means, for someone
like you
to say that, means and a bunch
of people
around you are actually paying
attention to what I do and...
send.
And... it means more than you
know.  I mean it when I say
thank you, that's
very cool of you
>> Hi, my name is
Nigel and I'm in the fifth
grade.  When did you think that
you were very famous?
>>
When did I find out I was very
talented?
>>
So you're saying I'm
talented?  I think we just
became best
buds.  Thank you so much.  I
don't know,
man.  I just... I try to work
really hard and do the best I
can
every time I get a chance, but
I'm still looking for that
talent.
Maybe one day I'll find it.
Angel.  What is your favorite
thing in the whole wide
world?
>> Favorite thing in the whole
wide world
besides ice cream and pizza,
you
ask?  That's a great question.
I love making people happy,
man.  It's a really good
feeling when you can
do something and put a smile on
somebody's face.
I guess that's why I, I do all
the stuff that I
do.  I like, I really like
making people happy.
Cameron in
fifth
grade.  Did you have a childhood
nickname and how did it make
you feel?
>> Yeah... so my childhood
nickname was John Cena, which
in the world
of WWE with these awesome
performers like
Stone Cold and Hulk
Hogan and The Rock and the
Undertaker.  They
wanted to use my name, and I'm
John Cena.  I
should have planned that one
better
>> The very last question
>> My
name is Antoinette, did
you count how many matches
you've won?
>> Say it again
matches you've won?
>> How many matches you
won?
>> Could I -- I'm sorry
what?
>> How many matches have you
won?
>>
How many matches have I
won?
>> Well... I've won at least
16.  Because I have 16
championships.
[applause]
>> And just keep in mind, in the
whole
winning and losing thing, in
baseball, if you only get a hit
three times out of
ten, you're doing okay.  Going
by that model, I'm doing okay
>> You
guys, your questions were
absolutely fabulous, let's
give him one more round.
[cheering and applause]
>> Thank you,
everybody.
I just want
to say thanks, not only for
your
questions, but everybody being
patient
and although I am here now, I'm
going to step over
there, so...
legitimately in the count of
three,
you can't see me.
could just stay
in your seats for a minute,
John wanted to take a picture
with all of you.
So... my colleagues over here
are handing out -- please
listen.
Shh!  Thank you.  My colleagues
are
handing to each of